[Applause]
good to see you guys
yeah highly competitive family yeah two
highly competitive families
that's healthy yeah all the aggression
comes from his mother just like my mum
so who is the talented chef who is the
strongest again
i absolutely love cooking but i've i've
learned it from mum really yeah i'll let
alone
do they tuck in or they're out there
like that for the whole night i'm glad
he's got big ears you know because he
can listen to me for once tonight yes
this is the most important part of
opening up and talking about what's
going through your mind now
all i want you to do is just cook your
heart i don't want to know what's going
through my mind now
everyone tell me give me a little
meet tonight's family brigade the
dawsons
retired sportsman matt is a rugby world
cup champion who is now as competitive
in the kitchen
as he ever was on the field tonight
he'll be trying to cook glay salmon with
crispy noodles and salad
progressing him duck with madeira and
cherry sauce and greek yogurt with
homemade honeycomb
and mixed berry cooling on his team is
proud mum and ex-dinner lady
lois girlfriend and former beauty queen
joanne
and completing the lineup his dad big
ron together
they're ready to tackle anything the
whole thing's teamwork you know more
about that than anybody all over it
all over it okay right starter clay
salmon with spinach and radish salad
yeah really nice marinade
noodles a little season a lot easier to
seize them now in a bowl than it is
in the pan and just place those noodles
in as it cooks it sort of sticks
together
the salmon that's been marinated with
honey soy
dijon mustard and lemon and ginger
grated ginger nicely seasoned
and salmon in as they've cooked on the
bottom we can take off the ring
yeah yeah and all you're looking for is
just a nice little light
crisp if the oil is cold yeah the
noodle's going to go greasy
salmon if there's a thick slice like
that turn out all four sides top bottom
and both sides yeah
vinaigrette soy sauce yeah honey grated
ginger
tahini okay which is really nice smooth
paste of sesame
seed to let the salmon rest take it off
that is ready to come out nice and
crispy a little bit of baby spinach
just use the vinegar to season it
lightly mix no seasoning
no don't need it because that's quite
salty now
look at the center of the plate and just
fan out just a little touch of dressing
over there
okay because underneath sometimes the
radish can be a little bit bland
around the outside noodles on
and then your salmon i'm so hungry
watching this have a little taste oh
yeah get familiar with it
right any questions no chef good very
good right the dawson brigade yes
first ticket on order four covers table
two for salmon for duck four yogurt yes
sir yes yeah
not too much in there joanne otherwise
it'll be a nightmare cooking and there
you go you only need
just literally there you go it's a nice
thin base there you go
that's absolutely fine make sure the
salmon you put in yeah yeah
pretty much the same size so they cook
evenly yes okay right
good there you go a little bit more oil
in there because you're scorching it as
a closer
yeah okay right what you're doing i
think you're taking them out too early
and when you put them in the ring you're
gonna push them down a little bit when
they come out
good girl they come out onto a nice
cloth the drain that's it well done
oh my they're going to be too you're
going to say that's too much now aren't
you uh yeah
way too much quick right radishes on
here
[Music]
so you would miss northern ireland it
was yeah 10 years ago is that right i
know it seems like
well it seems like yesterday i know it
was fantastic it was the best experience
of my life i have to say
and you still got the sash i have well
done
so you feel that salmon down the middle
beautiful nice and pink are you ready
yeah
just be careful yeah yeah up and on
there and i'll put the vinegar on
good girl right are you happy with those
yeah beautiful would you play with them
i love them yeah they look fantastic
right four more now let's go quick
slide off please double know
right time for jenna street farmer to
take her calves for a family day out
[Music]
for the past few months janet's been
bringing veal calves david and elton for
the f word restaurant
i should have trained that one for the
grand national last week they went free
range
definitely the right decision
janet's campaign to raise the popularity
of british ville began by trying to get
skill kids
interested in eating it
next you try to encourage consumers at
ripon market to buy it
can i tempt you with some fields due now
janet's tackling the beginning of the
chain
the farmers who should be rearing veal
today is the yorkshire young farmers
country show
[Music]
an annual bash that attracts hundreds of
farmers from all over the region
[Music]
janet needs to persuade these farmers to
keep their surplus dairy calves
and raise them for meat
in the barn janet's grooming her boys to
be the perfect ambassadors for her eat
british veal campaign
you look fantastic you do i don't want
any more [ __ ]
don't do one now it's showtime for david
and elton
but back at the country show things have
taken a turn for the worse
well it's pissing me rain in north
yorkshire i've got up
and i spent the first hour of my day
wiping mud
off the calf's bum and i wonder what
golden's doing
despite the weather janet's hoping a
squeaky clean veal cars will create
quite a stir here today
hello where have i got to go
[Laughter]
so far she's been doing pretty well
without them
oh [ __ ] okay you're gonna have to back
it jenna i'm afraid it's too tight
[ __ ] useless well hold on janet
you're gonna jackknife it well
it's a bit tight isn't it yeah all right
out here now
you're about to do there yep
i thought you're gonna make a right ass
to that but you did very well
janet sideshow is certainly attracting
plenty of attention
[Music]
now i want concert but these are
hard-nosed traditional yorkshire farmers
if she's persuaded them to reveal first
she needs to change their perception of
veal farming
hi hello what do you think of though
are we going to make you a lot of profit
i doubt it because it wasn't really
about making money on these two
it's hard to do with economics but if
there was a market for it
but they can't make them because it
costs too much money to go on
if we could persuade the british public
to eat veal
yeah yeah then it would be economically
viable for you to rear it you've never
eaten veal at all
if you don't find it you don't take
little calves there just no you know
you don't find it on the menu it's still
going to little carbs
now you're talking out your ass if you
don't mind me
because these are slaughtered at exactly
the same age as lamb i bet you eat lamb
are you not getting a lot of positive
a lot of people are very upset in their
ways yeah it's well i mean we are
yorkshire though
we don't like change janet's getting
nowhere
it's no wonder with these outdated
attitudes that there are currently less
than 40 veal farms across the uk
what she needs is some divine
intervention
maybe some refreshments will help the
young farmers see the light have a
biscuit
if we hadn't bought them they'll be shot
or
gone to the continent which i think is
cruel isn't it
it's a complete white house
success she's dug in her heels and
janet's finally persuaded some of the
young yorkshire men to consider taking
up veal farming
they look good dollo did you like one of
my leaves
thank you
with a bit of luck the fields of
yorkshire will soon be full of bill
calves
just like david and elton
after their big day out as standard
bearers for the british veal industry
janet settles their beloved boys in for
the night it's just
so exciting being a film star
the salmon's really soft and it works
really well with the noodles and the
radish and the spinach complements it
well because it gives a light side to
the dish as well
nice to see how was your starter very
nice thank you uh someone was cooked to
perfection
i just think that might have been well
there was a fine line between chris
being cremated with the new results
tonight
oh they're a little bit too colored
something you try at home
if he cooks it hold on a minute so who
wears the trousers in your house i wear
the trousers
he wears the penny something in the army
believe me
i'm in the ball signals give us an
indication in morse code whether you're
going to pay for this or not
daddy did it that means yes that's
[Laughter]
there's great texture and real contrast
between the noodles which are very
crunchy
and the salmon very soft succulent
beautifully cooked
right jose let's go results please here
we go whatever's in there i thought you
did a [ __ ] good job yeah
and the number of customers they're
willing to pay for their starter
45 out of 50. excellent
that is a very good starter hey
a very very good start but here's the
good news
the high score will be going so fast yes
okay
i've only scored 39 out of 50 for the
starter so already
you're six in front yeah keep it up yes
yeah now clear down on your sections get
ready for the main yes
[Music]
next up do we need this [ __ ] thing i
get all dressed up to go hunting for
essex birds are you taking the piss out
me or what seriously
[Music]
[Applause]
right welcome back to the s word time
for the main course
[Music]
progressively end up with madeira and
cherry sauce packed with protein
and absolutely delicious score
season rub hot pan
the secret here is seaming it on the fat
side of the duck breast
that'll give it a really nice crispy
color in the oven
8-10 minutes 190 degrees madeira sauce
hot pan olive oil shallots
mushrooms season
the secret of the madeira sauce is keep
it really nice and sweet slightly fruity
to help match the richness of the duck
madeira wine absolutely perfect for
making sauces with rich gaming me
reduce chicken stock
bring that out to the boil
sieve cut rest out
rest that's what i want all that flavour
in there in my sauce
cherries cut them in half
[Applause]
[Music]
and then add our madeira sauce back into
the pan
lovely butter
cool duck
[Applause]
sauce gretinum dumped with madeira and
cherry sauce so with camera eyes on
these
done
right matt so you can turn them on the
fact yeah put the other panel on get
another four on there
yeah yeah and then propose your
girlfriend hey
your son married wouldn't you i was as
long as he's happy with her then that's
fine by me
why do you think he's waiting so long is
he scared you're celebrating 40 years
ago
the perfect recipe excuse me boring
isn't it boring
he'll be going out with him 40 years
before he proposes to it matt
good killer keep on turning around it
cools the pan down so you get too hot
for you
place the sauce run we've got to start
working together the team again guys
yeah
yeah take that port on there for
yourself there you go
this one here the last one yeah very
nice hold on first table table line
please
[Music]
and what kind of food you fake black
thai food chicken
yeah you enjoy cooking when you get a
chance to do it
i like the achievement and the sense of
achievement in the end when you make
something quite nice
so you started young rapping right yeah
about that i didn't have been 14 i dj'd
first i used to mix drama bass
i started doing it for a joke and i
started taking it seriously once i could
vent them but at 13 years of age that's
young
by the time i was 15 yep i was on park
radio
outside the school i think one in the
morning until three o'clock in the
morning
seriously on park radio then go to
school yeah and ask everyone did you
hear me and they didn't because
obviously they were asleep fast
it's a lump of [ __ ]
it's from here it looks like a roast
chicken something like jamie oliver's
cookbook yeah
nicest thing i can think of this
actually came from a lyric i had at
least
have a lyrical lyrical tank boxing
machine like my name was frank going on
dirty going on stank rubbing and see
that back these banks i just took the
dirty on the stack made by the label
from here it looks like a rose chicken
with lemon thyme and herbs there you go
appetizers in here i think we should do
something together maybe you know that
we should do a song yeah man
you do this
how nervous were you watching your son
in the world cup oh i can't tell you
where were you for the fight we were
there
shaking okay uh a little bit huh you can
win the rugby world cup but you're
panicking putting one dump press on the
plate
last table they have usually cooked yeah
that's good
really well done yeah ron what do you
want this one
i can see where your cooking skulls came
from yeah and don't forget we like the
duck breast slightly pink so when the
sauce goes on top we finished cooking it
yes yeah
we don't serve the duck breast medium
right ronnie happy with those
thank you yes yes very good indeed
[Music]
right the best way to get rid of pests
is to eat them
some people are screaming about pigeon
as a food because we make the mistake of
thinking these dirty little buggers
are the ones you eat
but out of town there's a different
species and a different pest
wood pigeon are rich gamey and delicious
but it's because they gorge themselves
on millions of pounds worth of crops a
year
so to help farmers we should be eating
as many as possible
i'm in essex to learn how to shoot these
birds properly with the help of pigeon
big gun
gary green where'd you shoot it were you
looking for the head good head kill
you're done with a spoiler meat no
nice clean kill the lead passes through
the bird nothing worse than eating a
pigeon breast
and you've got these little small ball
bearings no that's right and it is it is
crop protection is what we're doing
i'm doing it for food yeah right i'm
starving
pigeon are one of the tastiest bursts to
eat but one of the trickiest to shoot
so i've opted for something as fast
agile and unpredictable as they are
to practice with
now bring a little bit [ __ ] closer
[Music]
these remote control planes will mimic
the pigeon's movement and if they don't
explode i'm a [ __ ]
shot [ __ ] pigeons are half that size
[Music]
[ __ ] tracking the bird attracting the
bird move off and fire
[Music]
well done direct hit that one
with my shooting skills improved i put
the fact that these planes were much
bigger than the size of wood pigeon to
the back of my mind
which is what i'm truly done right now
for the pigeons yeah
excellent thank you very much bloody
hell thank you that was good practice
we're heading to a rate field that
should be in full yellow blossom but
it's been eaten away
and if it isn't protected soon it will
be gone completely
gary's laid out decoys to convince
passing birds it's safe to land
and that's going to track them over yeah
sure you're sure you can get them from
[ __ ] coronation street look at them
huh stuck on the wall and it's crucial
they don't see us first
are you [ __ ] real seriously seriously
all jokes apart i mean do we need this
[ __ ] thing you will do we're talking
about a pigeon yeah
yeah but if we want them at 25 yards
this is what we've got to do
seriously i'm going to say
are you taking the piss out me or what
seriously don't this is it this is it
i've got mine here go on oh
we'll get arrested oh yeah
that's it we're ready to show
[Music]
all we had to do was wait
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
you're not expected to do well straight
off it takes a while
i am [ __ ] out
do you see it actually came up to me and
stuck the finger up shut on my head and
then sucked off
the pigeons were lightning fast and the
excitement was getting the better of me
[Music]
ah [ __ ] okay now
but there were plenty of birds look at
that lock for you and i had plenty of
cartridges
how about this one safety off shoot
and again yes
lovely shot well done well done there
holy jesus on your third shot well done
brock the dog is used to find the birds
quickly and prevent further damage to
the crop
yeah that's your bird sir you're very
fantastic palumbo columbus
about time no well done [ __ ] a top-notch
shot can bag hundreds of pigeons a day
like this
many of which are exported to the
continent i've been into it now and you
yeah where pigeon is very popular well
done
with gary's help i shot three in around
three hours
and they weren't going anywhere
well done [ __ ] i couldn't wait
a lot more difficult than you think you
know that oh yeah i knew it was gonna be
tough i didn't quite think it was gonna
be that [ __ ] hard
in the kitchen i'd pluck the pigeons
first but gary has a method i've never
seen before
so you're not plucking them no oh no no
it's too messy right
and takes too long yeah so i'm just
going to dislocate
[Applause]
the wings yeah
a little bit and just roll it out so
bloody hell and no mess
yeah and no feathers everywhere so
dislocate the just locate it and wind it
off
and then break out right handed that's
it
yeah i'll just pick that off there and
it'll skin right off
jesus hold on christ of mine is so much
quicker and a lot easier to cook with as
well you know
look how rich that is oh huh i'm very
lean
yeah lean healthy and [ __ ] delicious
gary's taught me how to shoot and pluck
them now i'm going to show him a
delicious way to cook his pigeons
i'm going to do a really nice salad of
pigeon
black pudding and pancetta
cut through the wishbone which makes it
easier to remove the pigeon breasts
nice thing about pigeon is slightly
gamey not too strong but bloody
delicious
that's what i want there though really
nice thin marbling of the fat in there
marinade in salt pepper and olive oil to
keep the pigeon tender
whilst i'm waiting cut up the pancetta
into nice sort of lardons
place the marinaded breast in a hot pan
beautiful
and literally one minute each side
whilst the pigeon rests
fry the pancetta in the same pan i'm
chattering
make a very very quick dressing i'm
making a dressing with olive oil and
cherry vinegar
the cherry gives it a really nice tart
exciting flavor
add salt pepper and lemon juice
[Music]
just a little tablespoon of the
vinaigrette so as the pigeons start to
cool down it absorbs
a really nice cherry vinegar and this is
where we get the black pudding
the black pudding gives it a bit of a
spice yeah just crumble into the bacon
that is a chef's dream that was
fantastic
delays the pan with sherry vinegar it
gives it a really nice sort of vibrant
flavor
drain it through a sieve onto a plate
that is fit for a king dress a
watercress rocket and frisje salad
and add the black pudding and pancetta
mix that through
colors are extraordinary but the real
star is the pigeons
for that i never thought an essex bird
could be so [ __ ] tasty
pigeon on a touch of vinaigrette
off you go my man cheers thank you tuck
in nice
crispy bacon and a really nice pink
pigeon
what a lovely way of eating black
pudding as well mmm in a salad crispy
fried and the bacon jersey
i can clearly cook but i can't [ __ ]
shoot you know
last table quick quick lowest run okay
well done good thank you chad ah sauce
hold on jojo yeah sure
i haven't had those combinations before
and the pak choi worked beautifully with
it really crispy the duck was really
tender
beautiful dish
[Music]
now how was the duck awesome really good
yeah i really enjoyed it something could
try at home
i reckon so yeah yeah yeah i thought the
sauce might have been a little bit thin
but other than that it was wicked really
good
good veg are you trying to shut off your
chest hair or you forgot your shirt
it's actually stitched into the t-shirt
what the hell yeah
i'm not i'm do you like your sandwiches
oh it's all right
that means no good to see it save room
for dessert yes
[Laughter]
the cheers is really succulent um the
madeira sauce wasn't too overpowering
and the cherries really added something
to the flavour it was just absolutely
delicious
it felt amazing to be part of a kitchen
cooking for actual people
you're just on the go all the time and
also you're thinking about it too
you know where you go to do this that
and the other we are here to have an
unbelievably good time
we also want to win right results may
cause jose
anything let's get it right the number
of guests they're going to pay for their
main course is
39 out of 50. good that's not much
that's not bad it's not bad so 11 not
paying what are the reasons
the sauce the sauce to watery anything
else
salt's too thin on the seasons under
season on the seasons
okay coming up are you a big fan of d5
mars bars
never had one eve bowman puts on a brave
hearty performance in the recipe
challenge
the brigade cook up a delicious dessert
of yogurt honeycomb and berry
cooley and tom parker-bowles takes
nose-to-tail eating to extremes
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful
welcome back to the f word now time for
the recipe challenge and tonight's
challenger is the heavily pregnant eater
though
good to see you good to see you if
you're losing call your baby gordon
right
well middle name did that do what you're
cooking
uh i'm gonna do haggis going traditional
scottish on your ass
with uh neep and tarties now where'd the
recipe come from
um mom basically oh really yeah i grew
up in a hotel so um
so your love of food comes from growing
up in restaurants
i grew up in a kitchen so it was it was
you know kind of instilled in me from a
really early age
it was my granddad and grandma started
the hotel and then my mum's one of seven
daughters i'll begin with e
and we've got elsie elizabeth edna elena
evie elaine and enid
that is very scottish so um edie's doing
a classic um
haggis basically so i'm gonna do a
really nice haggis hash brown
uh mixed with swede potato a little bit
worcester sauce onion and then i'm gonna
crumble my haggis
in to my hash brown fry it and stick a
beautiful fried egg on top of that
very good knife skills by the way nice
fine dice you're making me nervous
yeah you're only making harsh browns so
uh what else are you doing
tell me a little bit about the sauce
you've got cream whiskey mustard a
little bit lemon juice
kind of just makes it a little bit tart
and brings out flavors how many times a
year do you get a chance to get back to
scotland
oh i go back every couple of months are
you a big fan of d5 mars bars
never had one never tasted one here's
your chance now
just feel it first it just feels wrong
it's got legs on it oh god oh my god
bloody good i trust
they're ready look at that caramelised
onions at its absolute best
so fried them off a little bit of olive
oil salt pepper a little touch of sugar
and then worcester sauce
haggis is in the oven sweet and marsh
are pretty much kicked off so i've stuck
in some butter
some black pepper and some salt and uh
giving it the old-fashioned
mashup even is gonna have lumps in hers
and mine's gonna be a nice fine puree
it's another reek oh i wanna oh look at
that
i can do the first verse ah go on are we
ready for your honest sunset face great
chieftain of the pudding race i've been
the more you attack your place
that's what you can do huh yeah smell it
that smells delicious
pretty good i really need to make this
sauce now just need some taddies
yeah right french mustard yes yeah
irish whiskey cream from jersey there's
nothing scottish in there
and you're checking out the recipe but
look at you i've got pregnant brain
right i'm gonna start crumbling my mix
together now okay
so the idea now is just to crumble the
haggis through the potatoes
have you had contractions you had lots
of kicking and things like that few
things that you've never felt before
obviously it's not first
like what's that yeah don't get fed up
with people touching all the time no i
like that oh really
i like well i like people are not
touching it random strangers in the
street
wash your hands first of all come on
it's got haggis on there
excuse me we're going to infuse the hug
against each other
okay i thought the scottish baby would
like the haggis
i'd love to see you right now are you in
there big man
come on yeah that'd be nice
we've got a very own f1 baby come on
it'd be great
i'm dying to taste that do you mind look
at you catching the pips as well i'm not
finished yet
oh [ __ ] it's actually quite nice
it's actually cool no it is nice you
haven't put the whiskey in yet yeah no
no i don't mean to sound so surprised
but it is absolutely delicious
i've just fried mine finished with a wee
bit of butter yeah i'm gonna put it in
the oven
to get nice and crispy okay okay yeah
and i'll be two minutes
and then we're just ready to serve okay
get my egg ready
in terms of uh when you grew up placed
in the kitchen yeah i saw one dad
working hard involving restaurants you
never wanted to go into the industry
no i kind of i worked in it from the age
of 11. i needed to get out of that
environment small town as well i kind of
wanted to get to the bright lights big
city look at that
beauty let me just remove my room
look you've even done the layers as well
you are such a [ __ ] chef
go girl i'll get it simple if that wins
i am going to be pissed
huh right jose come back with the best
results
right here's tom parker bowles the human
dustbin
when we think of eating pork we tend to
think of sausages and bacon
but every part of the pig can be eaten
from the toenails through to the snout
[Music]
we're all looking for ways to save money
on food bills and the cheaper cuts of
pork
could be the answer one of these boys is
my pick there is in front of you
this one here yes aha i mean look at the
size of his bollocks that was a huge
to prove the entire pig can be eaten
those to tell i'm going to attempt to
prepare and eat 21 dishes out of this
porky little fellow
costing just over 100 pounds my boy
weighs 87 kilograms
about one third of that weight would
normally be thrown away i'm going to
find out just how far
a whole hog can stretch ah it just makes
me feel a bit odd just looking at this
awful's not much to look at but tastes
fantastic there's used in many great
traditional recipes we should all still
be cooking
so this being nose to tail nothing goes
to waste not even
the toenail so i'm going to take these
back
i'll be looking forward to eating these
some of the offal needs to be prepared
straight after slaughter so i'm taking
my pig to a specialist butcher nearby
tongue that's still connected to the
trachea okay
so all of this here is edible although
it's edible even the lungs there that
would normally be used for the something
like haggis and then it's back to london
to deal with the rest of the carcass
so this is the whole pig here we got
really isn't it everything
okay whole pig legs yeah loins
shoulders and the opposite the other
side we've got the same as well
seeing my entire pig laid out in front
of me makes me realize just how little
of the animal we normally consume
and just how daunting a challenge i've
set myself
very important the [ __ ] of course that's
going to be in my mouth later on
[Music]
today is the day i'm going to take on
the challenge of eating my entire pig
nose to tail i start with an italian
breakfast dish known as tobego
that contains kidney liver and black
pudding
beautiful now for the rest of the beast
traditionally one pig could provide a
family of four with enough meat to get
them through the winter
it's too much for me so i roped in my
wife and some friends to help me out
and what dinner party would be complete
without one of these
what did you guess what that is yup it
is the pig's
[ __ ] i mean look at that tongue
although they may seem obscure these
ingredients if cooked properly are
delicious
i'm using them to create a soup with a
difference
it's so sichuan style soup szechuan is a
province of china
the chinese are great offer eaters and
the chilean spices should make this dish
a real treat for the taste buds
i mean it's something really
fundamentally repellent about putting
knives into eyes even if it's a pig's
eyes
i mean look at this this is this is this
is that pig that nice little porker that
not very long that was running around
the field
transformed i'm going to be serving 21
sumptuous dishes including a wonderfully
decadent stuffed stomach of swine
half head roast glazed in honey and
cider
a delicate sichuan tongue eye and penis
soup
crisp trotters with toenail garnish
and testicles and brains sauteed in
seasoned flour
right on cue are my swine gorging
friends just in time for canapes
quite spicy now you're gonna tell me
it's like testicle or something
that's a heart
it wasn't too scary that bit of lung
liver a bit of heart but actually in
that spicy sauce
no worries at all so so far so good
hunting food
that's actually really nice i can't
resist snaffling the chef's perk and the
tastiest part of the head
a crisp pig's ear very very good we go
on to enjoy a feast of pig trotters
served on a bed of griddle radicchio
with herb
the envelope but vinaigrette actually
amazing
some succulent ribs marinades and chili
and expresso it's quite
um asian isn't it we saw the the nose
i'm sorry about three quarters of the
way down now and they've been no
complaints i'm really
enjoying it and the unusual fits more
than the
straightforward then onto my stuffed
pig's stomach
a great way to use the fat gristle and
skin season with thyme
sage and parsley it's like stuffing it's
delicious
up until now everything has slipped down
without insulin
however as we approach the back end of
the pig the last few dishes will really
test the stomachs of my guests
don't worry about the description this
is the bullets in the brain
[Music]
i'm feeling a little bit queasy
we are grinding boats what you do is
sprinkle it into this this soup
hopefully the flavor of the szechuan
peppers the chilli
will stop anyone tasting the bone the
[ __ ]
the eyes
[Applause]
final item
let's have a little
come and do the f word see the world
will be an eyeball
but it's not as bad as it looks
pretty
you're all man
it's the thought there's nothing wrong
with the taste i'm just thinking that i
got an [ __ ]
come on that doesn't taste nice surely
tastes a bit of [ __ ]
tom nice to see you myself oh well very
well good i can't believe
tom parker bowles ate a pig's [ __ ] i
i had to eat it
it sounds sensationalist but i wanted it
no to tell to show that you can eat
every single bit of a pink
i was fascinated by it you know that was
it tasty it was like eating it just a
very long braised muscle it was just to
prove that we waste too much of a pig he
weighs you know a third of the pig
we don't need awful enough i mean the
true definition of offals varies yes
yeah how would you define well the
official thing is off fool i and when
you hang up the car because it falls off
but that doesn't take in the deer it
doesn't think in the ass when it's like
in the brains doesn't take
so actually there's anything inside that
most british hate yeah but it did have a
serious point the fact that we don't eat
enough for the pig these are cheap
good nutritious cuts that you just
ignore yeah now i know we're entering
our credit crunch so
honestly on the menu there should be
more awful eating right liver
kidneys yeah detroit is cheap you know
chips yeah but yeah we all hated earth
discussion cooked well it's delicious
but this is the thing we don't eat any
of these pots the supermarkets just wrap
all these things and tell us to be all
these nice boring bits it's rubbish we
should eat
most of it not that you missed a trick
what a big trick because the world's
oldest condom made back in 1640
yeah was made from pig intestine did you
try that yeah
what did i try to
it was just to prove that we shouldn't
be scared of these things rather than me
really good to see you
oh jesus
right time for dessert
[Music]
homemade honeycomb with mixed berries
this is the secret
the honey inside the honeycomb hot pan
sugar water
glucose syrup honey
[Music]
the color is getting darker and darker
what we're looking for is a really nice
light toffee baking soda
when the baking soda hits the camera it
creates a really nice light bubbling
sort of eruption almost like a live
volcano
out and onto a tray once it's cooled
down
straight into the fridge mixed berry
[ __ ]
raspberries blueberries sugar
lavender essence be very careful it's
very pungent incredibly powerful
blitz
[Applause]
sieve the color
is beautiful honeycomb smash
not too small otherwise the honeycomb
becomes powder yoghurt
honeycomb into the yogurt mix
so it's got this really nice textured
yogurt with honeycomb
folded through take your berry cooling
and just drizzle on top dried lavender
flowers
finish it with some tiny fragments of
homemade honeycomb
and that has to be the perfect summer
dessert
yogurt with mixed berry [ __ ] and
homemade honeycomb
done
that is perfect lois yeah really well
done sweet please don't get any of it on
your skin yes
it can seriously burn you okay
that's fine perfect well done all the
berries in don't
forget lavender essence one
two this is not the same lavender you
put in your bath it's a culinary
lavender essence
give a little shake mat just a little
shake
please mix too much yogurt with a
honeycomb otherwise it will go soggy
guys got honeycomb throughout yeah good
and then get your ladle
don't add your cooling you're very cool
into all the glasses that are even yes
too much in the first one chef lois
they're beautiful
really nice see that's weighed out
perfectly well done
absolutely perfect glassy's nice and
clean guys yeah
right first table table nine please yeah
lois is table yeah lovely
[Music]
[Applause]
coming up i prove you can eat healthily
even when you're cooking for a huge
family
for dinner again
welcome back to the effort now time to
find out who's a tall blonde talented
scottish cook
and who's eating them
quite salty that's really rich that
would be a really good hair for
breakfast
for the look of this one i think this
one looks fantastic yeah it's a shame to
break into it really
i'm not sure about that smalls i like
the way you can taste the different
flavors
the time of the night well i get really
excited right give me the good news they
prefer
hash brown flake with haggis and a nice
fried egg go on
um come on then it's edith oh goodness
what yes what do you mean it was lighter
yours they believe was a bit too rich a
bit too rich yes
and what was the score three two five
mills oh
i say get out of there you belgium
cabbage
that is a [ __ ] joke and you may have
won but
it's not for you it's a we gordon yes
okay my mum went on the f word
come on hen oh at my kitchen
oh no five now
i believe everyone can cook healthy food
and you're never too young to start
i've come to darlington county durham to
meet lindsey and ian dade
and their huge family
ian works as a bin man and like lindsay
he's also a part-time student but
feeding eight children is no mean feat
and they're struggling to cope
we feed them stuff we find in the
freezer this easy quick convenience food
i feel guilty feeding the kids frozen
food i know it's not
the best food for them i know they're
not getting enough nutrients but
um it's it's i don't see your way out
hello how are you donny hi
nice to see you all now eight of them
yeah eighteen are you mad no oh
no we enjoy it we enjoy it are you
stopping at eight or you're going for
double fingers stopping at eight
stopping at eight so go for that how do
you make a bit of baby weight you see
who stops this um uh well i do the
internet shopping
chicken kievs fish fingers
roasted vegetable selection roasted
frozen and then defrosted back in there
it's it's an easy option i've lost a lot
of inspiration for cooking
i do i need to get them eating healthy
again fresh veg
yeah is absolutely crucial who wants to
go shopping
yes lindsay needs to get excited about
fresh produce again
and get the kids involved too to make
the shopping easier
ask them for yellow peppers with no
bruises
and some yellow peppers with love oozes
and you can ask for the cucumbers nice
firm dark green cucumbers please and
there's a nice firm dark green cube good
girl
lovely your staff see you next saturday
you heard that yes
okay great i'm gonna show lindsay how to
make a fast fun and healthy meal that
the family will love
right this dish is exciting very
nutritious for the kids
and more importantly very very simple to
do
leg steaks of lamb they're low in fat
for lindsay and great for making the
ultimate finger food for kids
so needs a simple marinade seasoned
oregano
mint rosemary i've dried tarragon do the
kids like garlic
love it yeah grate it the zest of lemon
lemon juice we'll leave that in the
fridge 45 minutes to an hour
the trick to getting kids eating
vegetables is to make it fun i'm gonna
get the kids making their own salads
who's gonna be the best you've got okay
one minute each starting from
now off you go come round come round
quick i want to see the best one
sprouted cucumber
five four three
two one and stop
nice are you ready for the kebabs
yes out with the marinated lamb
delicious finished with mushroom nice
and hot
lightly drizzled with olive oil and then
lamb
yogurt into the bowl yogurt contains
potassium calcium and plenty of other
vitamins
fresh mint
it also makes a fantastic dip not just
for the lamb also
for the salad as well so it becomes
really nice and healthy pita bread
couple spoons of the sauce kebabs
mmm tyler what do you think it's nice no
more frozen roasted vegetables promise
who would like this for dinner again
everybody that's right
take care sweetie good to see you
thank you very much yeah early christmas
present yes
use them now bag it stop at eight for
god's sake
it was just wonderful it was perfect it
was orgasmic it was
everything you'd want in a pudding it
was just perfect wonderful
the lavender really overpowered the
dessert and
um the yoghurt seemed to be slightly
fizzy
right off yes yes you look [ __ ] up
absolutely shattered yes right jose
let's go resolved
please okay the number of guests
that are happy to pay for the dessert is
23 or 50. hold on a minute
did anyone put hot honeycomb in the
yogurt
what else and the honeycomb being quite
soggy as well
honeycomb was soggy oh it's a bit damn
pointing that isn't it really that's
just under half 107
out of 150 damn where does that put us
it's not the worst unfortunately it's
not the best
good effort yes it's been a pleasure
having the dawson brigade in the kitchen
yes
apart from that obviously yes now thank
you very much go get yourself a big
ice cold beer you deserve it well done
[Applause]